- Honestly, building a
cat fort with someone is
one of the most intimate experiences that
two or three humans can share together.
(upbeat techno music)
- Hi, my name is Jack and
we're at my apartment.
What we're doin' today
is we're gonna build
the world's greatest cat fort.
For my cat Jenkins.
This is Jenkins' current cat fort.
This little tree in no way
represents what Jenkins deserves.
Jenkins gives and gives and
gives, and all he does is give.
I feel like a cat with a heart that big,
deserves a home to match.
We're all prepped, everyone is here.
We've got all the stuff and
it's just the right time
because every day at this time,
Jenkins takes a long nap.
We're gonna have to be very, very quiet
so we don't wake him up.
But I think we're gonna get this done
before cat nap time is over.
I'm excited, guys let's do this!
♫ Pull, rack and roll ♫
- Hi, I'm Tanner.
I'm helping Jack build the cat fort.
- (laughs)
My name is Summer and I'm
here to make sure that
any cat involved in this
fort has a good time.
- [Jack] Do we have enough boxes?
- Yeah.
You got a lot of cardboard to work with.
- Jenkins has one lifelong passion,
and that is a passion for cardboard.
I think he's gonna be
really, really excited.
(box dropping)
- [Jack] Shh.
You wanna have a periscope
coming out of here,
so he can get in and
poke his little head out.
- You wanna pull the
knife towards yourself.
So, here's what I'm doing
is I'm making a shelf
that's gonna sit on the inside of a box
so that he can jump up
and jump out the roof of the box.
- I've got two triangle-shaped pieces,
they've both got slits cut in them
to kind of slide in there to get
(box banging)
right here.
(bird singing)
It's a cat toy that's in there.
- I am slightly worried because
we have a huge amount to do,
including building a courtyard and
putting crenellations and decorations
on all of this stuff.
Crenellation is what
you see on battlements
of a castle that goes like this.
So, I'm creating a little
crenellation station here,
so that we can have some of this stuff
all around the side of the fort.
- We need one more here
to match that side.
- Oh right, but you're
gonna have it go up.
- No.
- [Jack] No?
- [Jack] Tensions are a little bit high.
My main thing is I hope that
Tanner's not displeased with me.
He said I was gonna be bad at this
and he didn't wanna trust
me with the job, so...
- Jack, how's that crenellation goin'?
- Good man!
Oh Jesus.
Well, this is the best I can do.
If he doesn't like it...
(drum roll)
- Good!
Well, I kinda lost my wind
there for a little bit,
I thought we weren't gonna
get this thing done but,
I think we're gonna do this.
Pque-pque, pque.
Okay, the cat is about to wake up.
We've got five, maybe 10
more minutes if we're lucky,
and we have so much more to do.
I don't know if we're gonna
be able to make it in time
before he gets out of bed.
(energetic drum beat)
- Wooo!
(upbeat guitar music)
- Okay, so we're finally finished.
This is the completed
structure, here's what we have.
We have a big skull right in the entrance,
which is to intimidate Jenkins's enemies,
but will not intimidate Jenkins
cuz he's a very brave boy.
Everything in the courtyard here
is centralized around this one pole.
It's wrapped with rope so Jenkins
can really scratch on it if he needs to.
But it's also got a
lotta string hanging down
so he can play and bat at the string.
He can get inside onto a big
step that's built up in there.
Get onto the top where he
can look at his drawbridge.
He can go inside one of these boxes
and look out of his periscope.
Or he can relax in this
lovely Fort Jenkins
right on the far east
side of the building.
This is the finished cat fort.
- I'm gonna get out of here.
- (laughs)
- It may be time to wake Jenkins up and
see what he thinks of it.
- Let's get Jenkins!
Let's get Jenkins!
- We're about to bring him in.
This is gonna be his first
reaction to the fort.
I don't know what to expect.
(suspenseful music)
(laughing)
(whimsical music)